happy new year everybody all right if
you're like
if you're like our family we did a
little online shopping through the
holidays so we're going to have some
changes to make in the new year
beautiful skies out there everybody it
was a chilly holiday season for us for
sure
hey over the weekend we had a meteor
shower it was the quadrantids
not one of the biggest of the seas of
the year i should say but it started us
off
and there's a whole list of meteor
shower shows
for 2021 and these are the dates it's a
lot to take in
and a quick minute here but i'll put it
on my facebook page
so go there and make some plans to be
out and catch these the perseids and the
geminids
are always the best ones august and
december best ones of the year but i'll
post those
and we'll be talking about them of
course nate and i and sally and ted will
let you know when there are good meteor
showers coming up
lots of 30s around the fringes of the
valley and outside the valley it's a
cool january morning
we've got some clouds out there as you
could see from the
camera shot and rain and snow moving
into the west
we're not going to get in on any of that
we're going to keep some heavier clouds
this morning those should be thinning
out
mostly sunny skies in the afternoon
we'll look for a high of 61 today normal
high
for early january january 4th is 57 so
we'll be above that
should get a lot of sunshine for tuesday
and milder mid 60s mornings will stay
cool
but we'll look for 60s pretty much
through the entire week
the weekend later in the weekend looks a
little cooler 57 by sunday so passing
clouds here and there
mixed with sunshine that's how our first
week of 2021
is shaping up